este embargo se producirá en dos fases
por una parte a finales de este mismo
año
se paralizarán todas las importaciones
de crudo desde rusia porque vengan a
través del mar esto significa más o
menos un poco más del 90 por ciento del
total de importaciones de petróleo por
otra parte en una segunda fase habrá
todo un embargo de todo el petróleo que
llegue por oleoducto el embargo no hay
una fecha exacta de cuándo se va a
producir va a ser más adelante aunque
los países europeos se han comprometido
a que se haga lo antes posible son los
aspectos técnicos que aún se tienen que
acabar de perfilar a lo largo de esta
semana pero lo más importante sobre todo
que esto es un duro golpe para rusia hay
que tener en cuenta que los 27 países de
la unión europea pagaron alrededor de 70
mil millones de euros por el petróleo a
rusia esto puede significar un duro
golpe para la economía de rusia pero
europa ha asegurado que es momento de
dar este paso a pesar de que no se trata
de un embargo total como en un principio
sin embargo este embargo se convierte
sobre todo una victoria para el primer
ministro húngaro viktor orbán que
durante todas estas semanas ha estado
bloqueando un acuerdo porque insiste a
en un embargo por por el oleoducto
porque hay que tener en cuenta que
hungría y república checa- enteramente
de rusia por un solo oleoducto y con
este embargo se da un poco más de tiempo
porque hay que tener en cuenta que estos
países además no tienen salida al mar
aún así la unión europea con este
acuerdo consigue al menos un embargo
aunque sea parcial y en todo caso
también evitan un mensaje de desunión